[Music]
after the events at the pink Cove
Fairview power plant the new alliance
between General Anderson's true sons and
Natalia sokolova's Black Tusk has led to
a team composed of both factions as they
attempt to work alongside each other
stovepipe is the leader of this group
and the main target but in order to find
him we need to take out his four
lieutenants
with chunks now gone we're on to Target
number two Batman
uh Ben 10 Ben 10 yep
[Music]
Lieutenant Martin bantam's background as
a U.S army drone operator gave him a
unique perspective on warfare
he was able to control unmanned aerial
vehicles and use them to Target enemy
combatants without ever setting foot on
the battlefield
however as time went on Phantom would
become desensitized to the violence he
was causing from afar as he transitioned
to become a member of the true Sons
Bantam continued to use his skills to
Target enemies from a safe distance
however his beliefs about responsibility
began to morph into a twisted
justification for his actions Bantam
convinced himself that he was not
responsible for the deaths caused by his
drone strikes as long as he did not
physically see blood on his hands
he was able to ignore the fact that his
actions were causing real-life
consequences for other human beings
this cognitive disconnect allowed him to
continue his violent Behavior without
any remorse
it's clear that bantam's mindset is a
dangerous one
by disconnecting himself from the
reality of the situation and the harm
he's causing he's able to justify his
violent actions and become a danger to
those around him
Lieutenant Martin Bantam is a cautionary
tale about the dangers of Detachment and
warfare and how it can lead to dangerous
beliefs and behaviors
prior to the operation Bantam expressed
his doubts about collaborating with the
Black Tusk he had always been a loyal
true son but the recent alliance with
the Black Tusk had made him uneasy he
knew that their ultimate goal was to
gain control of the capital and Rule it
with a nine first
but he wasn't sure that their method was
something that he was able to be a part
of
[Music]
hold tight what are we waiting for I
wish I could tell you above my Patriot
or above yours too sir it's neat to know
but do you know I know enough
are you sure about these people sir I'm
sure that if we want to win this war
Lieutenant we need allies but these
allies do you have enough food yes do
you have housing and clean clothes
yes do you have enough weapons and
medical supplies yes do you have enough
mortars enough to level the city so do
you feel like you have the tools and
resources at your disposal to win this
war absolutely how do you feel about our
new allies now better General good
hold tight and wait for orders
it was torn between his loyalty to the
true sons and the Practical benefits of
working with the Black Tusk but
ultimately he knew that the true Sons
couldn't have kept going in the way that
they were their resources were dwindling
and the situation was becoming
increasingly dire
the true Sons were in disparate need of
a game changer and this could be it
yeah the castle castle
the castle settlement yes sir what about
the dc-62
extensive decontamination efforts have
been made since Captain Wilson's attack
looks like they're getting ready to
reopen the settlement oh
for them while he's been seen in the
castle as well makes sense they were
always close no news on the other Target
Natalia I'd like to hear that from you
do you mind giving her a call there's
nothing to tell well she'd like to hear
it from you I'd rather not why not
sure she scared the [__] out of me
any updates no ma'am eyes on the Target
no ma'am do we at least have
confirmation that he's still on site no
ma'am do we have anything we have
footage of him being brought back to the
White House after Coney Island he was
badly injured no aerial footage since is
he still alive no way to confirm it this
time if he's alive they they never let
him outside
bantam's aerial drones have shown what
is happening at the castle sediment and
the huge efforts going into rebuilding
it but also the movements going both in
and out of the White House
they are now very aware of Captain
Lewis's involvement with the castle
being rebuilt as well as Wally
they are also now aware that Baden
Schaefer was taken to the White House
but they have no idea if he's still
alive or not
I wonder if my suspicions are correct
about the White House coming under
attack but the potential for Schaefer to
be alive with all the secrets he holds
be the reason they attack
retrofit more mortars I'm gonna need
more dc-62 thank you for telling me
Lieutenant General does that mean you're
going to send more DC 62 yeah at this
point contamination threats may not be
in our best interests physical
contamination what are you implying
rumors about radiation sir oh rumors
what rumors about the plant no St Louis
what about St Louis you really don't
know do you excuse me there's nothing to
know I can't tell if you're full of [__]
or your new friend is teaching you to be
a fantastic [__] liar watch your tone
Lieutenant I don't give a [__] about my
tone I want to know if I need to worry
about radiation poisoning sir
this Combs continues the rumors that
were started in the chunks Manhunt and
while we know that the attack on St
Louis aren't just rumors I'm beginning
to think that this isn't just a nice
crossover to the novels
this is going to feature more heavily
going forward but I really can't put my
finger on Hal at this point
dirty bombs radiation how would this
assist either side going forward if
these were brought to DC or New York
or maybe that's the point perhaps those
crazy bastards known as the outcasts are
going to be the reason for the Black
Tusk and the division to call the truce
for a little while but if that was the
case wise McManus Circle over and maybe
Anderson tried to hide it from everyone
[Music]
following the successful elimination of
their first Target chunks division
agents quickly received Intel on
Lieutenant Martian bantam's whereabouts
it was revealed that he was actively
operating within the Foggy Bottom
District of Washington DC which prompted
agents to launch a full-scale operation
to take down the true Sun outposts in
the area
with each Outpost that was taken down
the agents gathered more information
about bantam's location which eventually
LED them to the heavily defended
compound of the Potomac Event Center
the true Sons were abundant in Supply
and it was clear that this was going to
be a challenging mission
despite the odds the division agents
were well prepared and had the necessary
equipment to take on the heavily
Fortified Compound
the white death with its overpowered
Talent determined proved to be a game
changer and it felt more like target
practice than a national battle
as agents made their way through the
compound they eventually came face to
face with Bantam himself
in an uncharacteristic move Bantam
decided to engage in the fight himself
showing a level of Courage that was
unexpected from someone who had
previously hidden behind a screen
however his efforts were no match for
the well-trained division agents
with one swift Bullet to the face Bantam
was taken out of commission
it's unclear whether he would have put
up much of a resistance if he hadn't
engaged in the fight but the agents were
relieved to have completed their mission
successfully
the elimination of Bantam would bring
the one step closer to tracking down
their main target
stovepipe
Target 2 has now been eliminated
not gonna lie this one felt like more of
a filler Target this was probably the
smallest bio that we've seen on any of
the targets up until now and I felt that
the comms really didn't give us too much
to think about but these could all add
up in the future
I must apologize for the dip in my
uploads lately real life has been
keeping me very busy these days not
Cyclones or anything this time just my
job Etc
though I may be quiet and not responding
to a lot I'm always reading so if you
think I may have missed anything or
perhaps there is a topic you'd like me
to look into just let me know either
here or on any of the social media I use
even if I don't see it my wife will
usually let me know
anyway I'm going to end this one here
thank you very much for watching and
extremist malice extreme remedia
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you